un petit peu les mix c'était un magazine
Public Florian a précisé parce que du
coup on veut pas dormir c'est Stéphane
Plaza voilà qui a cette image de genre
un peu idéale et joue beaucoup sur son
image aussi pour être un peu
ambiguïté sexuelle et voilà et donc le
magazine Public révèle que l'animateur
serait un véritable tombeur il y a trois
femmes qui ont témoigné et qui ont parlé
de lui alors voilà ce que dit la
première voilà et elle dit c'était des
je t'aime en permanence tout le temps
donc je veux t'épouser on va vivre
bientôt dans ma maison de campagne chez
moi parce que soi-disant ils
travaillaient voilà et pendant qu'il
voyait cette femme là il y avait une
deuxième femme qui voyait qui elle dit
on s'est rencontré par un intermédiaire
d'une amie en commun il m'a fait des
grandes promesses me comble de mots
d'amour évidemment les deux ne savent
pas qu'elles existent pas encore non pas
encore alors elle dit aussi d'autres
phrases cette deuxième femme lors d'un
weekend en amoureux une fille dont le
prénom s'affiche sur ton téléphone ne
cesse d'appeler donc elle a piqué le
téléphone elle a dit qu'il y avait une
fille c'est un indice et s'éloigne pour
répondre ça aussi hein c'est un vrai
truc et s'éloigne pour répondre il
tourne son téléphone voilà et donc la
fille dit profitant de son sommeil je
regarde son téléphone je comprends cette
fille était avec lui depuis quatre ans
avec quatre ans qu'il était avec deux
femmes en même temps et je termine
l'histoire et ce sera à vous de vous
lâcher il y a une troisième femme du
coup qui arrive également à cette
troisième femme qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit
elle depuis 8 ans il est avec elle
depuis 8 ans
c'est sûr que ça se complique un petit
peu et surtout alors attends juste
Florian parce que là presque people je
pense que peut-être essayer des choses
depuis des années il faut rappeler quand
tout a commencé et on en avait parlé sur
ce plateau c'est quand il avait donné
une interview en disant qu'il était
héros sexuel on en avait fait un petit
sujet ici parce qu'effectivement il y
avait le doute il y avait l'ambiguïté
qui existe non c'est jamais si c'est
drôle ou pas ici c'est la grosse tête
c'est pour rire ou pas à l'époque lui je
pense qu'il l'a fait dans un cadre très
simple il pensait pas que ça allait
exploser comme ça par la suite mais
après plusieurs plusieurs femmes là
c'est dans public mais moi à closer j'ai
été contacté par plusieurs d'entre elles
dont une en particulier qui voulait me
raconter toute son histoire avec
Stéphane Plaza avec les côtés positifs
les côtés négatif moi j'ai senti
l'histoire un peu il y avait des choses
que je sentais pas donc on n'y est pas
allé
c'était pas clair journalistiquement on
pouvait pas y aller et après publique à
faire un autre travail à poursuivi
peut-être un peu plus moi sur ce que je
sais c'est que public avec d'autres
choses c'est-à-dire que là c'est un
petit peu la partie émergée de l'iceberg
il y a des choses peut-être un peu plus
dur derrière ce qui est écrit ce que je
sais aussi c'est que Stéphane Plaza est
foudrage il a une seconde parce que ça
veut tout et rien dire c'est quoi des
choses un peu plus dures que ce qui
était écrit bah c'est-à-dire que
apparemment les femmes qui ont témoigné
auraient pu dire des choses un peu plus
un peu plus un peu plus difficiles un
peu plus un peu plus accusateur à son
égard voilà mais c'est pas vraiment on
accuse personne quelqu'un qui trompe
c'est pas un crime regardez juste le
dessin derrière on dirait un procès à la
cour d'assis de alors que c'est juste
trois fois qui sont fait tromper
finalement
excusez-moi mais juste moi je suis très
choqué par cette information je vous le
dis clairement je trouve ça incroyable
que on en discute même pardon
prélever la main tu vas dire un truc je
trouve ça incroyable on en est là quoi
on en est à ce que des filles expliquent
qu'elles ont une histoire d'amour avec
un mec qui est connu tu es en train plus
ou moins de il y a laissé penser par
contre bienveillance que le mec est de
plus dur c'est quoi le truc plus dur à
la PPDA elle a eu l'eau alors ce mec que
je ne connais pas j'ai jamais rencontré
que j'aime plutôt bien que je respecte
moi seulement sa vie privée est étalée
quoi
décider de témoigner mais c'est
important tu réponds à Florian c'est
compliqué de laisser entendre des choses
dans dans 15 jours publiques ou un autre
journal creuser balance sur 15 personnes
qui t'ont connu dans ta vie privée et
face à une espèce de portrait de toi
enfin je sais pas un moment donné c'est
à Laurent parce que c'est important je
suis d'accord avec toi moi c'est aussi
pour ça que que j'y étais pas allé
simplement ce que j'essayais de dire et
je ne m'en sais pas plus donc je le
précise mais c'est qu'apparemment les
femmes en question sont extrêmement
remontées pour des raisons qui dépasse
peut-être le cadre de l'adultère etc
en fait soit il y a un truc
préjudiciaire et elle porte plainte soit
il y a rien de préjudiciaire
mais sur l'une des trois alors moi
stéphane est un ami donc j'ai fait
exprès parce que alors il est
effectivement si quelqu'un est
extrêmement romantique et tout c'est
surtout trois jeunes femmes qui veulent
absolument raconter un truc sur elle et
plein pourquoi sur l'une l'une des trois
ni des choses qu'il aurait pas plu et il
y a un dépôt de plainte d'accord
tu dis je sentais j'ai un truc que je
sentais pas moi je trouve que tu as bien
fait de pas y aller hein que si on en
parle aussi justement pardon Laurent si
on en parle dans cette émission c'est
justement aussi pour mettre le focus sur
ce genre d'article ou ça devient
aberrant parce que au pire des pires si
Stéphane Plaza décide de tromper sa
copine avec quelqu'un ça ne regarde que
lui et sa copine et s'engueule il sépare
mais jusqu'à maintenant tromper façon on
devait accuser tous les gens qui
trompent on se la panure sur le plateau
tous les casseroles tout le monde sur le
plateau tout le monde a des casseroles
quoi alors pas tout ça en même temps
alors va y aller mais Sophie si je peux
me permettre on est aussi comme souvent
malheureusement sur des nanas qui ont
aussi un peu envie de se faire remarquer
et le sentiment aujourd'hui on n'a pas
de preuve on est en train d'étaler sa
vie privée qu'il a envie de se taper 3 4
ou 6 ou 12 nanas c'est son non mais
c'est son problème à partir du moment où
elles sont au courant alors elles disent
qu'elles sont pas au courant j'ai un
petit doute sur cette histoire parce
qu'en fait à un moment donné quand un
mec avec qui tu es au lit et qui reçoit
un message à 3h du matin alors pas
toujours ailleurs mais c'est vraiment
les deux sur les derniers au courant
mais souvent en tout cas ça nécessite
pas d'exposer comme ça sa vie pour
l'instant et de l'accuser de la caber
c'est un gentleman je le connais
personnellement j'ai un petit doute sur
la véracité des propos des noisettes la
seule chose je te laisse la parole
Sophie est-ce qu'on peut peut-être lui
reprocher à lui c'est de jouer en
permanence un petit peu sur sa sexualité
donc forcément il attire un tout petit
peu les les rongeurs comme
il apparaît plein plein d'histoires
j'aime bien cette phrase de publier mais
qui remue la merde sans la merde pardon
elle est très vulgaire mais ne va pas
chercher aussi des choses ne va pas
provoquer les mauvais mais on lit un peu
ce genre de journaux pour ça aussi enfin
moi c'est moi je le lis pour ça pour
savoir qui est avec qui qui a rompu avec
qui qui a trompé c'est un petit peu
quand même un petit peu la ligne
tutoriel aussi de ce genre de magazine
People quand on débute dans ce métier en
général et qu'on débute on débute en
fait on critique mieux on aimerait bien
y être retourne les pages on y est
jamais on aimerait bien y être pour y
être comme il y ait lui là dans ces
conditions-là non pas comme ça bien sûr
ça doit être compliqué pour lui mais
effectivement il faudrait peut-être
vérifier ce que raconte les nanas et
après
17 phrases incroyable et elle dit être
dans Voici c'est terrible ne plus y être
c'est pire évidemment c'est exactement
c'est ça qu'on est absolument c'est
comme quand on demande une photo dans la
rue quand on te demande t'empêcher de la
faire mais le jour où on te demandera
plus ça fera encore plus donc voilà on a
fait le tour ouais non juste pour
conclure par rapport à ce que disait
Isabelle est-ce que c'est vrai que tu
l'as dit c'est très important les
réactions de femmes et celle qui m'a
contacté en particulier ce sont faites
immédiatement après sur une espèce de
coming out hétérosexuel c'est à dire à
ce moment-là elles ont voulu certaines
moi c'était ça c'était pas pour dénoncer
des agissements marquer leur territoire
et dire il est à moi je veux juste te
dire un public et je connais pas qui
dirige tout ça donc je m'en fiche mais
je important il faut un petit peu des du
Plaza mais on sait pas du tout ce qu'il
y a derrière je te jette ça comme ça ils
ont fait ça sur ma croix un moment il
serait peut-être je suis pas ok pas gay
il y a rien derrière il t'envoie un
article ça serait bien que il y a un
petit peu de matériel derrière avant
d'envoyer un truc qui est un feu de
paille et on sait pas ça fait du mal je
suis pas un public non je sais bien que
c'est à cause je pense que c'est pas une
Plaza va attaquer publique et qui va
gagner
alors là ce petit moment évidemment très
drôle si vous êtes chez vous là je pense
que si vous avez votre mec à côté ou
votre femme ou votre mec mec ou femme
femme vous savez comment c'est regarder
c'est forcément quand on vous dit des
choses c'est comme quand on vous dit les
signes d'une maladie en général tu
commences à les avoir mais j'ai ça moi
ça me la jambe sur comment reconnaître
que votre femme ou votre mec vous trompe
première chose c'est la plus classique
c'est qu'il ne vous laisse plus accéder
à son téléphone ça malheureusement
il y en a qui étaient là
généralement tu décides une maison pour
tout au début de ta vie moi c'est pas le
cas tout le monde mon code sur moi donc
il y a pas de souci que tu dis
clairement à tout le monde le code je
donne pas donc tu as pas tout d'un coup
quand tu deviens amoureux quelqu'un de
dire eh tu as pas mon code non c'est pas
de donner le code mais c'est par exemple
de laisser son téléphone comme ça à côté
traîné et de laisser les petites
notifications
je connais plein de copains contre trois
téléphones officiels ils en a un autre
qui est planté
et cetera vraiment
tu veux tu peux crois-moi il faut savoir
aussi que les personnes qui vous offrent
énormément de cadeaux
des cadeaux de culpabilité exactement en
général on essaie bah si on offre pas de
cadeau tu as un goût j'attends prenez
cadeau quoi
[Applaudissements]
alors cela dit c'est vrai que Cyril
cette semaine dans TPMP avait dit il
faut toujours offrir une petite route
mais pas un gros bouquet la petite rose
qui romantique le gros bouquet tu as
déconné donc les radins on est bien
quand quelqu'un sait quand il cherche
constamment il ou elle le conflit avec
vous c'est à dire qu'il veut tout le
temps rentrer en conflit avec vous pour
avoir une bonne excuse pour se séparer
pour ce s'embrouiller pour revoir une
bonne excuse pour partir le soir oui bah
je vais balader tu vas casser la tête
c'est une très bonne excuse nous sommes
dans le public qui fait comme ça depuis
tout à l'heure
parce que c'est vrai et attention et le
dernier signe et ça c'est imparable les
personnes extrêmement jalouses sont les
plus infidèles
sont capables et savent que de se
retrouver leur arriver donc ça c'est le
plus plus alors je sais pas évidemment
chez vous si vous reconnaissez mais
peut-être ici si les gens sont honnêtes
est-ce que quelqu'un ici a déjà été
trompé dans le public
tout le monde n'avez jamais été trompé
qui a déjà été trompé
des qui a trompé allez euh
moi je peux vous dire mon mari qui garde
son portable tout le temps c'est
toujours moi qui lui retrouve donc
j'aimerais bien savoir comment il
pourrait faire il a peut-être un
deuxième blender
alors les stars comme juste pour un
nouveau qui prennent le polyamour il y a
eu hélène de Fougerolles incroyable
Hugues Aufray oui vous savez que c'est
incroyable il est marié avec sa femme
depuis 1951 et il a une deuxième femme
une deuxième amoureuse comme dit depuis
2005 qui est beaucoup plus jeune mais
les deux sont au courant d'accord
sa femme avait dit bon moi à partir
d'aujourd'hui c'est fini donc on reste
en contact mais
le tour du sujet il y a une différence
entre le polyamour qui est officiel est
validé et l'adultère c'est deux choses
distinctes à partir du moment où tu dis
à quelqu'un moi personnellement ça m'est
arrivé d'être en couple avec enfin en
couple avec quelqu'un de fréquenter
quelqu'un et lui dire on ne s'engage pas
il y a rien d'officiel tu fais ce que tu
veux je fais ce que je veux c'est
différent que d'être en train de se
faire mais c'est vrai qu'en tout cas sur
cette émission c'est le sujet où tu
étais le plus investi
merci merci Ayem